what Jeb Bush is not a conservative he
doesn't need to be speaking at our
conservative conference you know we're
giving him a chance he was a good
governor so we'll see ya at least my
type of conservative were repulsed by
Jeb Bush I hate a Jeb Bush not happy
about him not necessarily full-fledged
conservative are we talking about all
conservatives awful so I like Jeb Bush I
want to hear more about Jeb Bush I think
people are not thinking third Bush a
charm that he has a father and a brother
who were presidents and might make them
a little weary to elect a third Bush
he's a big government establishment
rhino
I happen to love her kind of stupid kind
of dumb I think she has been grossly
misrepresented and the underestimated I
I really have no opinion I mean I can't
speak for everyone bama fan she had her
time in the spotlight it didn't work out
I'd not short we love Sarah Palin Donald
Trump is in it for the money does it
once it he just wants attention iconic
good businessman I really have no
opinion brash I'm not a candidate at all
funny he's a businessman mixed reviews
true to his beliefs I think Donald Trump
keeps buying his way here every year I
like him he had a great speech earlier
nobody cares about Donald Trump I'm not
giving you a comedy gold here but the
fact is is that it's really hard to
ridicule a man who's a self-made
billionaire but a little bit kooky he's
a failure a week President I failed
failed president awful the liar is a
fake liar